et on envisage pas de remplacer les
ramoneurs par des machines
qui rentrent dans les chaufferies ou qui
rentre dans les tuyaux pour les nettoyer
jusqu'à présent
et je crois pas que ça sera pour demain
ça
[Musique]
en Alsace les cheminées ont recommencé à
fumer et tout alsacien doit se conformer
à un arrêté qui précise que les
cheminées servent au seul usage
domestique doivent être nettoyés au
moins tous les trois mois lorsque les
foyers qui correspondent auront été en
activité c'est-à-dire d'octobre à avril
et le travail doit être accompli par un
maître ramoneur chez d'Orne on est
Ramoneurs de père en fils à l'aube
l'équipe est au complet les tenues sont
soigneusement brossées les visages
impeccables
les ramoneurs traversent la ville
déserte il faut travailler tôt avant que
les chaufferies se mettent en marche
[Musique]
la visite du ramoneur a été annoncée par
une inscription à la craie avant de
monter au grenier on salue les
locataires
[Musique]
pour les petites cheminées le travail
est relativement simple et rapide les
portes de ramonage permettent à
nettoyage efficace les chaudières sont
également entretenues par les ramoneurs
[Musique]
le travail se complique lorsqu'il s'agit
d'industrie possédant un équipement
important nous sommes dans une
charcuterie
ici il faut nettoyer les fumoirs
entièrement recouverts de suit
cristallisée qui résiste souvent au
grattoir
on peut ensuite s'occuper de la cheminée
inutile de préciser qu'un ramoneur ne
doit pas être sujet au vertige
faisons connaissance avec Monsieur d'or
monsieur dorment depuis combien de temps
êtes-vous ramoneurs
quel âge avez-vous quand vous avez
débuté j'avais 14 ans pour faire mon
apprentissage n'est ce pas alors après
j'ai passé mon brevet de compagnon et
après on pourrait de mettre vraiment
l'heure est-ce que le métier était plus
dur quand vous avez débuté
et le coq et tout ça alors maintenant il
y a le mazout c'est quand même plus que
qu'avant
et du fioul c'est pas la mort des
ramoneurs vous avez tout de même du
travail
il y a quand même du travail parce que
le mazout ça donne aussi la cheville
que vous avez choisi vous le métier de
votre père cela n'a pas besoin de
problème non non
non
au début on crache un peu mais à la fin
de compte
sur la santé non je pense pas c'est
belle tenue là est-ce que vous les lavez
est-ce que vous les nettoyer oh non ça
casse trop vite ça peut-être à moi c'est
cassé
en Espagne et puis
ça bouffe le tissu pour deux trois mois
c'est cassé et on envisage pas de
remplacer les ramoneurs par des machines
qui rentrent dans les chaufferies ou qui
rentre dans les tuyaux pour les nettoyer
jusqu'à présent
et je crois pas que ça sera pour demain
ça
à la mi-journée les ramoneurs rentrent
tobercaï la matinée a été dure ils
accomplissent des performances parfois
dignes d'alpinistes
ce n'est qu'en début d'après-midi que la
journée s'achèvera pour eux à cette
heure-là les chaudières pourrontonner
les cheminées seront libérés de leur
suit les outils seront alors nettoyer et
rangés jusqu'au lendemain dans la cave
du maître ramoneur je t'en dis à un coup
d'oeil indiscret
[Musique]
monsieur dans ma journée a été bonne
pouvez-vous nous expliquer à quoi
servent tous ces instruments bizarres là
que vous portez ça sert à nettoyer la
cheminée vers le haut c'est pas la
partie extérieure du toit ça s'appelle
comment
qui sert à nettoyer la cheminée vers le
bas
est-ce que vous avez à l'épaule là parce
que ce qu'on tous les ramoneurs à
l'école
la suivre sortir des portières de
ramonage en bas et la petite brosse
de petits pois qui
plaît à peu près 7 kg ça veut dire si
j'ai une prix qui est tombée dans une
cheminée n'est-ce pas au lieu d'ouvrir
la cheminée de la cassée en bas on
essaye de la faire passer avec ceci
alors ça ce sont ces instruments
principaux durant mon âge tout bon
rameneur doit connaître le maniement de
ça
les jeunes apprentis comment les
formez-vous au départ au départ ils nous
suivent ils nous observe comment nous
nettoyons une chaudière comment nous
nettoyons une cheminée on les apprend à
tenir une chaufferie propre et ramasse
la saleté il lui a cheminée ou pour le
début et puis surtout que la propreté
c'est le principal pour un apprenti qui
qui fait ce pas trop de saleté dans les
escaliers qui suit bien ses pieds comme
des remonte la CAF et puis tout cela
est-ce que vous avez eu des apprentis
qui ne sont pas habitués au métier oui
oui mais c'est rare généralement en
général
au bout de trois quatre semaines ça se
voit si l'apprenti il aime le métier ou
si ça lui plaît pas ou il a peur de la
suivre comme ça vous voyez est-ce que
les ramoneurs alsaciens ont une
réputation particulière ou assez
ramoneur on pense toujours ramoneur
savoyard oui mais même à Strasbourg
parce que vous avez beaucoup de
touristes qui nous ont déjà arrêté sur
le soleil
ramoneur vous permettez qu'on prenne un
flash de vous et puis j'ai quand même
très connu vous savez les ramoneurs en
Alsace
ramoneur de Marie dans un intérieur
impeccable
surprenons-le à la sortie de la salle de
bain
monsieur don de vous aussi vous avez
choisi le métier de ramoneur comme votre
père et comme votre frère pourquoi
sur le matin on est toujours à l'air
toujours ça change tous les jours et
même plusieurs fois par jour puisqu'on
va voir plusieurs clients
à l'air des transformations multiples
des chambardements incessants ils sont
encore là et n'ont pas envie de
disparaître leur silhouette noire se
dresse même sur les toits des buildings
les plus modernes que leur sourire
éclatant dans leur visage noirci
continuent à apporter à nos villes cette
note humaine et rassurante après tout ne
dit-on pas qu'il porte bonheur
[Musique]